how are things with your children today
um you know it's a work in progress it's
um
you know you just have to watch this
show as it plays out you know i'm not in
georgia to south florida
um and they're seven hours away um so we
are in production
um who knows what the future holds did
you film it all with your kids this
season
um we we had a little sit-down talk
that's the only thing that we have so
far
and what was that experience like
because i i know you've been a bit
estranged
um it's been it was rough but like i
said you just have to watch the season
to know
and you know it that was a hard
situation i will have to say that um
do you keep up with your girls on social
media i know they have a lot of ideas
yeah oh yeah i'll be i i'll be
commenting on the thing
when anna goes live i'll be all up on
this they know it mama don't ever stop
being mama
in addiction or non-addiction um
you know so you know you have to keep up
you know lana's got them what i like to
call stripper eyelashes i'm not telling
her then things are too long
i know alana's been taking a little bit
of heat online from people who have
opinions about her having fun with
makeup how do you react to that as a mom
um she's a 15 year old child and she's a
10th grader
in high school you know she's got
friends
she's always been that divalicious even
at the age of four everybody knows
that's what everybody fell in love with
she's a glitz girl and glitz girls love
hair and makeup
and you know um she's not that
four-year-old child
that everybody fell in love with 10
years ago she's a 15 year old
you know teenager and she's the 10th
grader i mean she's a teenager like come
on guys
yeah um you know a big a big focus this
season
seems to be um the the emotional
aspect of your relationship with your
daughters
and your relationship with gino seems to
be a huge
obstacle between you we all hated gina
because mama picked him
and drugs over us how do you feel when
you watch your daughters talking about
that how do you feel when you watch them
i mean as a mom you know it's hard you
know they say like in the 12-step
program you know try to make an amends
you know that's one of the steps in the
12-step program and
as long as not hurt you or the other
person recovery
just like addiction came number one and
it sounds selfish as a mom
but recovery is even more selfish and i
have to
i have to be good for me to be good for
somebody else
so i i know that you've expressed
verbally how how sorry you are for the
way it is
played out how are you showing your
girls
that you mean it and that you want to be
a part of their lives
you know alana is still living with
pumpkin currently
so you know making phone calls you know
making just showing them like
staying present sounds bad me staying
present on my social media
um you know me you know sending them you
know
pictures or you know trying to get
somebody to talk to them through
somebody else
and trying to realize that you know stop
um a lot of people beat me up for that
for being so far away from my
children but it's like how can i be good
for somebody else
if i can't be good for myself we can't
just forgive and forget overnight
you've let a man come between your kids
she's got to prove to us
that she's all better do you think
there's a
a world that can exist where your
daughter's
find forgiveness in geno in order to
make amends with you i definitely think
there will be
um i said it's just a work in progress
um
i think it will because me and the girls
have always been closed and i think a
lot of fans and a lot of people period
think that he had the influence of drugs
but the reality is it
is i was the one with all the drug
dealers i was the one that was hooking
him up with a dope
um so you know it's just like i said
it's
the best way to describe it to somebody
it's a work in progress it's an everyday
thing
if it came down to you got to pick us or
you got to pick him
what do you say to that i mean that's a
no-brainer
i mean you always pick your kids men
come and go
kids and kids kids and some family
always stay
you mentioned that alana is still living
with pumpkin
is it a goal of yours to have alana come
live with you again at some point
i mean ultimately yes that would be um
the actual reality of it um but who
knows i mean
you know i'm only you know i don't know
i'm only i'm only that one person and
you know they always say that you know
they were working on my timeline and now
you know
i've learned recovery that i have to
work on their timeline but i don't stop
i don't ever stop trying and that's me
as a mom even in my addiction i wouldn't
stop trying
you know watching pumpkin she's 21 years
old she's a loving wife
she's a loving mother and she's also
taking care of alana how do you feel
knowing that your 21 year old daughter
really does have a lot on her plate
um one i mean i'm very proud of her for
foremost um
you know in our family has always been
closed so
does she have to step up no did she
choose to step up
yes am i very grateful for that yes and
i will always be
she's done a damn good job but you know
we've always been so close
that i knew without a shadow of a doubt
when this situation happened
um was it i felt great about it no
sorry hell no i didn't but
you know i knew that
pumpkin wasn't going to allow to happen
to her
yeah she's a very strong woman what do
you think
june it will take to ultimately
reconcile
with your girls i honestly just think it
will be time
time and showing them and being present
and being never going away and
showing them that hey i am i am clean i
am
sober i am doing the things i need to do
to get back into your life
so that to me is what
isn't going to happen overnight and i
know that trust me would i like my
fingers just to snap and be like that no
it didn't happen like that when i was in
my addiction and it's not going to
happen like that in my recovery
mama june we have really gotten to know
you over the last decade
since you have opened up your life to
the world and you invite these cameras
in to capture the moments the good and
the bad
i'm curious how will you know when it's
time
to say goodbye to the cameras um we've
had talks
about that man you know like in the past
me and the kids have
um you know october 12th of this year
will be
a decade on tv a decade so everything
that we've done has been number one
and that's us giving 100 of our life
real
life unscripted to the world you know
who knows we may be
now the kardashians retired maybe we'll
take over their spot
we don't make kardashian money no but
it's been
enough to be able to support us
throughout the years we represent the
crazy dysfunctional side of america
well whether people love you or hate you
we can't deny you always keep it real
mama jews always keep it real over the
last
10 years i would love you to kind of
take a little stroll down memory lane
what is the one moment that you're most
proud of
and what is the one moment that you wish
never made it to air or maybe you wish
that cameras hadn't been there in the
first place
um the most
proudest moment i became a grandmother
for the first time
i became a grandmother's two time
watching the kids grow up
it's been a crazy adventure um
the one thing i would hope that never
would have hit air
i don't think any of it honestly because
it's real
it's real life bringing the reel back
into reality tv
and not have a script i mean i regret me
going into addiction
yes but a lot of people don't realize
that before even
here comes honey boo boo i had when i
was 20 years old back in 2000
you know i had you know i started doing
math
i did it off and on to 2015 until i met
gino when he told me i went cold turkey
um and then two years later i picked up
cocaine addiction
um those things you know
i don't wish i would have done that but
i'm glad that i went
public and the reason why is because
so many people's life has been changed
because that
people have told me on my instagram that
they have became clean
i've helped them become clean so for me
do i regret anything that showed on tv
no
there are so many opinions about you
mama june
what do you want the world to know about
you
how do you want people to perceive you
um people can perceive me however the
hell they want to we're not
caught up in the hoopla of the reality
world or the entertainment world
we're real we're down to earth we'll
give you this shirt off our back
we'll help anybody we can and i think
that
through last season and now in my
recovery i have gave back to
hundreds of thousands of fans and
they've gave back more to me than i can
ever give to them
and so for me that's the only thing i
can say is that we're real what you see
is what you get whether we're on camera
or we're off camera we loud we proud
and it is what it is it ain't what it
ain't
[Music]
you